And now to you, Scoutmaster.
So today, in a little bit, we're going to be talking about older Scouts.
I have a story that I think is really funny.
A number of years ago I had a couple of older Scouts who were fascinated with the television show
Beavis and Butthead.
If you're not familiar with Beavis and Butthead, don't waste your time.
It was kind of a cool show, okay,
But they just embodied being Beavis and Butthead 24 hours a day, seven days a week, it seemed,
And you know, on a weekend camping trip, and then another weekend camping trip
and then a week at summer camp. that can get pretty old.
I stumbled on a way of getting them to stop without asking them to,
And that was when myself and another one of the adult leaders within their hearing
started repeating all of the things that they were imitating,
and not doing it in a cynical or mean way or anything like that,
just doing it and enjoying it along the same lines that they did.
And I can remember the look that I got from one of them when they discovered that we were doing this.
And you know what,
Once they discovered that we were enjoying that and having a lot of fun with it,
they never did it again.
It worked like a charm. It was amazing.
Hey, this is podcast number 370..
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast. This is Clark Green.
A very brief few words of introduction today.
Last week's podcast about patrols and planning, where I answered email questions,
received several very nice comments over on Facebook.
Thank you, Larry Jennings, Pete Parris and John Mello.
Thanks also to Heath, who got in touch through the website.
Thank you for your kind words
And thank you to everyone else who has been in touch via email this week.
You can get in touch with me at Clark at scoutmastercgcom.
I'll tell you more about that when we get towards the end of the podcast,
But today we're going to be talking about older Scouts.
So let's get started, shall we?
Let's talk about older Scouts
Now. to begin with, when I'm talking about older Scouts,
I am talking about Scouts that have left intermediate or middle school
and moved into high school.
Most of the time, that means they're around 14 years of age,
One of the first things to notice. in the United States,
our children move from elementary school to a middle or intermediate school
And then from that school into high school.
So you got to ask yourself what's going on there.
Why is that happening.
There are developmental things going on in young people's lives
that make this a good idea.
Now, good, bad or indifferent whether you like the way that this is done
or not, this is the way it happens.
Now, if we go and look at the Scouting program that the BSA offers,
we have Scouts from 11 to the age of 18..
In a Scout Troop, which is really unusual if you compare it with the rest of the world of Scouting,
Because the last time I checked the oldest age that a young person could remain
in a Scout Troop as a Scout was in Germany and that was the age of 16.
And there was some kind of special circumstance there.
That we keep Scouts in a Troop until they reach their 18th birthday
is an anomaly. It's kind of unusual.
So in the BSA we have this interesting conundrum to work with.
We have younger Scouts who are 10 and a half, 11,, 12, 13 years old,
and we have older Scouts who are 14,, 15,, 16,, 17 years old.
What happens a lot of times is you volunteer, you become a Scout Master
and there may be older Scouts involved with the Troop.
There may not, but at some point you understand
you've got some young people who are very different developmentally
and have a different set of concerns and interests than your younger Scouts,
And this sets up several things that can be a conflict.
It sets up things that can be problems, and I hear about them pretty regularly.
And then we act as though we're the first people to discover this thing
and we've got to come up with a solution for it, because our older Scouts
don't seem to be as interested and engaged as they used to be.
I'll give you a really good example of this.
When I directed our summer camp and served on our summer camp staff,
there was always some kind of drive to create an older Scout program,
Thinking that the reason that these Scouts aren't coming back
is because they've already done most of the stuff that we offer in a program.
so we should have some cool stuff just for the older Scouts to do.
And that makes a lot of sense, doesn't it?
But you know what? It basically never put a dent in the numbers,
because amping up the wow factor of the program
or trying to appeal to older Scouts with special activities and things like that
is what I call the bread and circuses approach,
And if you're not familiar with the metaphor,
bread and circuses means that you're placating real concerns
with superficial means of appeasement and diversions and distractions,
without really getting at the heart of the matter.
So let's talk about the heart of the matter.
If simply turning up the wow factor doesn't keep older Scouts engaged,
what really keeps them interested and engaged, what keeps them around?
So before we try to answer that question,
let's really observe the situation that we find ourselves in
when it comes to working with older Scouts
And let's ask ourselves what do they want to get out of the program?
They want to become Eagle Scouts as one standard response.
They're kind of in it for getting the Eagle and all that that involves.
and some Scouts become discouraged by that drive
because it seems like it's a means to an end
and they just want to get it over with.
And as positive as that drive can be for them,
it can also lead to some cynicism about being involved in everything
and I'm just kind of holding on because I want to become an Eagle Scout.
So let's set that whole part of it aside.
Let's realize that that is a thing, but it's not the thing.
So what do these Scouts, these 14 to 17 year old Scouts,
what are they looking for and what do they really want?
In the simplest of terms, I think they want what everybody wants
and that is kind of to hang out with their friends
and associate with people their own age,
You know. as I mentioned, they want to pay attention
to their own advancement and progress.
They want to have increasing levels of independence and freedom
to discover and explore without people looking over their shoulder,
and they have this desire to be considered an adult.
They're in those years where childhood is being left behind
and they start looking forward to life as an adult
and they're pushed and pulled in many different ways
and, like everybody else on the face of the planet,
they have a desire to be useful and appreciated.
Now let's look at what we Scouters want from our older Scouts
As far as association goes. we think it's really really important
that they associate with younger Scouts
and we come up with all kinds of schemes to make that happen.
With older Scouts we're happy to have them pay attention
to their own individual progress and advancement,
but we really want them to pay attention
to younger Scouts advancement and progress.
In those two things we're kind of working counter
a little bit to what they want.
We have a set of expectations that they may not share
and then, where the expectations align a little bit more
is we want them to develop a sense of responsibility
for others as well as themselves.
We want them to return what they have received
in positions of responsibility
and we want to begin to trust and count on them
as we would an adult.
Some of the expectations an older Scout has
and a Scouter has are kind of in alignment
and some of them are a little bit opposite,
Especially in the idea that we want them to associate
with younger Scouts on an ongoing basis
and take responsibility for them
and their advancement and things like that.
That's normally where kind of the point of friction comes in.
Next, I would like to point out that you should always be having
a challenge working with older Scouts.
You're always going to have that challenge.
It's never going to be solved
and your results are going to be all over the map.
and that's fine, because that's the way that this works.
Give it a little bit of time,
a little bit of experience and practice.
You will get better at it.
But we are dealing with people
in a particularly mercurial time of their lives, right,
Where they are looking for identities
and they're seeking things out,
trying to figure out what they're going to do.
They're pushed and pulled in all kinds of directions
by all kinds of forces
and we can choose to be one of those pushers and pullers
or we can choose to be a bit of a refuge
from all of those pressures.
So to become more successful
in working with older Scouts,
we need to recognize that most of us have a few blind spots.
One of the first big blind spots is we have a program
and we present the program
like we present a well-prepared dinner, you know,
and we lay it out there
and we're very disappointed
when our Scouts turn their nose up at it.
And if that's happening on a regular basis,
we've got to stop driving the program.
rather than working with individual Scouts,
We have to balance the interest of the individual
against the interest of the group,
and that is a process that never stops
and it's the way that we occupy a lot of our time as Scouts.
One of the other things we tend to do
is we complicate the simple and simplify the complex.
So when you're dealing with a challenge
with older Scouts- and younger Scouts too,
you know the most obvious answer
is probably the right answer,
but not necessarily 100% of the time,
When we listen carefully to what individual Scouts are telling us.
we will be better armed to divine
between the complex and the simple.
The way Scouts behave, older or younger,
is an expression of a number of complex causes and motivations.
They will act in ways that are a little confusing.
They do silly, stupid things on occasion
because they are working out how you become an adult
and they're not necessarily interested in listening
to what you think about how they ought to become an adult.
You were not very interested in listening
to the adults around you during this time of your life.
I would guess
You were much more interested in finding your own way
and you made a number of mistakes
and you made a number of bad choices.
Who do you need to be
in response to what is going on in their lives?
Well, the last thing you need to be is their friend.
Now I have enjoyed a pretty good friendship
with a lot of my older Scouts,
but that friendship has to kind of be at arm's length,
because I have more important work to do for them
and I have more of a responsibility for them
than just being their pal.
I also have to be an authority figure at a time in their lives
where they're liable to make some bad choices
and I have to have the authority to deal with those things,
and friendship can kind of dilute that authority.
There is a razor's edge of a balance
When I'm talking about having some authority
and everything like that.
that doesn't mean you're unapproachable,
you're unpleasant, you're gruff, you're mean.
It means that you accept the idea
that you are going to make unpopular decisions
or take unpopular actions every once in a while
and you don't let it keep you up at night,
because this is your role.
You're an adult, they are children,
Your sense of responsibility and judgment
is a little more honed and attuned
and you have the benefit of more experience than they do,
and sometimes you will have to impose that upon them
In response to who they are and their time of life.
what else do we need to be?
Well, we need to be very good observers and listeners
and in my experience, you cannot simultaneously listen to
or observe what other people are doing
and judge them at the same time.
So there needs to be a part of your attention
as an observer and as a listener
that is free of coming to judgment
as you observe and listen.
Do you understand what I'm saying?
You have to occupy a much more neutral territory
before you decide that you're going to make
some kind of a judgment about the propriety
or the advisability of a certain course of action.
and this is why it's good
to have a little bit of a remove
from being invested in winning the friendship of older Scouts,
because you need to exercise a whole lot of patience
and if we allow our emotions to take over
and we feel slighted or disrespected,
then we're going to run into problems.
So the basic answer to the question
of who do you need to be
when it comes to working with older Scouts
and responding to what they need
is: you need to be an adult,
You need to be kind, courteous,
considerate, loyal, fair
and you need to have some empathy.
You need to be approachable and friendly, of course,
but you need to differentiate between the idea
of the responsibilities you have for young people
and the idea that you're going to be their friend,
So seeing misbehavior or problems
as a personal affront
from somebody who's supposed to be your friend,
rather than just the general process
that young people are going through-
making poor choices,
trying things out-
your sense of fairness
is going to come from objectivity,
and our own desire to be liked
and appreciated and respected
will sometimes prevent us
from being what we need to be,
and that is decisive and directional.
Now, when it comes to working with older Scouts
in positions of responsibility,
I'm going to reiterate
my often made plea
to not become their boss
or their drill sergeant
or their teacher,
but that you are a partner with them
in this work.
and while their position of responsibility
has some practical outcome,
we need to also realize
it's really part of the game,
because it's their opportunity
to learn skills and to develop character
that's going to help them
for the rest of their lives.
Now, if you think you can teach them
or think you can imbue them with character,
you're going to be disappointed,
because the nature of people
at this age
is to try things out, to experiment
and to do things for themselves.
so partner with them
as they go through this evolution
of discovery and talk to them about it,
not substituting your judgment
for theirs,
but asking them how they've judged
a given situation
or how they see the outcome of a certain action.
and I've found over time
this is the most fascinating,
the most satisfying aspect of my work
as a scouter
is to be able to have a dialogue with them
about what they're thinking,
the decision making processes
they're going through
and how they're judging different situations.
I can't do that
if I'm going to be their boss,
their drill sergeant or their teacher.
I am much more interested
in their judgment,
in their actions, than I am
telling them how they should think,
how they should feel,
how they should judge given situations.
if you open up a dialogue
about those things,
you'll get to express your opinion at some point.
but your opinion isn't the most important part of this.
discovering what they're up to
and what they're thinking is much more important.
while we're on the subject
of working with older scouts,
let's talk about the dark side of the moon,
and no, I'm not talking about
Pink Floyd,
although you might want to revisit that.
if you haven't done that in a while,
it'll put you back into that mindset
a little bit.
if you remember the NASA lunar missions,
there was a point which the spacecraft
was on the dark side of the moon
and out of radio contact with Earth
and, if I remember correctly,
it lasted about 30 minutes or so
and I can recall this being broadcast on television,
everybody kind of biting their nails for 30 minutes,
desperate to hear back from
the spacecraft.
while working with younger people
having a son or a daughter.
there's going to be at least some period
of their lives where they are on the dark side
of the moon. they're out of radio contact.
you really can't tell what's going on in there,
just like the NASA missions.
you're kind of biting your nails, wondering
if you're going to get back in contact.
you will.
you won't be able to see what's going on,
you won't be able to hear what's going on
and very little information is going to be shared with you.
but you will
get back into contact.
another good thing to talk about is
the way that most young people need to express
their own rugged individualism.
now, it's kind of interesting
that over 30 years of being a scoutmaster,
working with scouts, that that
rugged individualism is really
not very individual
at all. it's pretty predictable.
you know a certain kind of way
of wearing your clothes
or doing your hair. patterns of
speech and attitudes
come up and everybody
who wants to be a rugged individual
follows those particular paradigms
right. it's kind of amusing
to watch that happen. and think back
for a moment. when you were that age,
what things were you doing
that were driving your parents right up a wall?
was it what you were wearing,
the way you kept your
hair, the things that you listen to,
the things that you read,
the general attitude that you assumed
with them. it's very likely
that you did something
and now take that experience
and build it into your experience of working with older
scouts. they're going to do something
that's just going to drive you crazy
and if you want it to be repeated often,
let them know that you don't like it.
some things are worth going to the mat over
and battling for, and these things
are always big things.
save your energy for the big things
and let the little things alone.
sometimes I've had older scouts
go up with purple hair
or they fall in love
with a hat or some element
of costume
that they have to wear 24 hours
a day, 7 days a week.
a lot of times they will fall out of love
with their scout uniform
or they will take a cynical approach to something
I consider to be sacrosanct and sacred.
well, I'm going to save
my powder for things that
really matter and do my best
to do nothing but
raise an eyebrow at the other things.
and the uniform thing is something to talk about
for a moment, because
I think it drives a lot of people crazy.
I know it drove me crazy. a lot of times
my older scouts would show up no uniform
or their uniform would be very sloppy
and kind of slapdash,
and I wrestled and fought with that for a while
and then I just kind of decided
that I had more important things
to do than to worry about this
and so stopped paying
all that much attention to it.
that might raise your eyebrows.
I would just encourage you to put your energy
where it really matters,
and that's the development of character
and assuring everyone's safety and well being.
the other thing that I believe is important
is not fighting against the idea.
older scouts want to hang out together
and are not necessarily interested
in just kind of hanging out
and spending time with scouts who are several years younger.
now just like uniforms.
if you want to pay attention to that
and you want to spend a whole lot of energy on that,
then you can advise against it.
in last week's podcast I was dealing with
a question that came from
there was a problem with patrols
because all the older scouts would leave
their patrol assignments and just go hang out together.
well, that means that they ought to be in their same patrol.
you know the answer that comes back to that is:
well, if they're not in patrols with younger scouts?
what will the younger scouts do?
and my answer is: the younger scouts will be fine,
they'll be in a patrol,
they'll elect their patrol leader
and then the older scouts will help them
find to being in their patrol
on a permanent basis.
because if you're looking at it from
a purely logistical and management perspective,
it makes perfect sense.
but when it comes to scouting,
it doesn't necessarily make a whole lot of sense
because you're not managing employees,
you're dealing with people at a very murcury age
and you are working against
what is happening in the rest of their lives.
well, I've got to say,
have absolutely zero problem
with getting older scouts to work with younger scouts
to instruct them,
to help them with their advancement,
to help them on camping trips and backpacking trips.
it's not a problem.
it would be much more of a problem
if I was to require them
to be in the same patrol with those younger scouts.
let's break this down by reviewing
what we've been talking about.
if you are running into challenges
and difficulties working with older scouts
or you have a sense that
they're not really buying into what's going on
and you can't trust them or depend on them,
I would not be surprised that that's happening,
because that is what is
generally going to happen.
don't be dismayed. you have lots of company.
if you'd like to smooth out these challenges
and difficulties, then
consider what older scouts want.
consider how that
may correspond with what you want.
consider who you need to be
in response to who they are
in their lives at the moment,
and begin watching
and listening and see what needs to change.
if you will
take my advice and remain
eternally optimistic-
always see that glasses half full
and look for
positive things
rather than negative things-
the whole thing will begin to get better,
because there's a lot of positive there.
spend your energy
on looking for that
and cultivating that.
if you spend your energy resisting
things that you don't like,
to build on the things that you do like.
so I hope that's helpful.
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this.
you can get in touch with me pretty easily
and I'm going to tell you how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks so much for listening to this
370th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
keeping in touch is pretty easy.
you can go to scoutmastercgcom
where you'll find lots and lots of articles
and lots and lots of podcasts,
and you can subscribe
to receive updates to the blog and the podcast
by email.
we're on facebook. we're on twitter.
that's another way that you can keep in touch with us.
there is a contact form
available there at the website,
or you can just email me.
I'm always available at clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
C-L-A-R-K-E
I need to remind you that I am not sponsored by
or endorsed by
any scouting organization
whatsoever.
I am not an official voice for anybody
other than myself.
isn't that just pitiful?
what has happened here
is I simply have a way of recording a podcast
and publishing it on the internet,
and you just happen to be listening
and speaking of listening,
listen to this,
as we hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir?
until next time, everyone.